If IKEA is the global face of
Sweden, Walmart might be America’s.
But despite, apparently, being one of
the country’s “most patriotic” brands,
over half of all Walmarts are
located outside the United States.
Its 10,500 stores are scattered across 24
countries, 46 brands, and 4 continents,
from Botswana and El Salvador to the
strange and exotic lands of Ohio.
Target, on the other hand,
operates in just one country.
In its entire 120-year history, it
only once tried to expand overseas.
In a mere two years, Target opened
over a hundred stores in Canada,
failed spectacularly, and became a textbook,
seven billion dollar example of what not to do.
It was such a disaster, in fact,
that someone wrote an actual two-act
play re-enacting the events. It was even
performed in one of the abandoned stores.
Sponsored by Nebula, the platform
created, owned, and loved by creators.
Sign up for exclusive, early, and
bonus content from PolyMatter and
hundreds of other channels
you’re guaranteed to love.
The Greek Tragedy known as Target Canada
begins with a company called “Zellers”.
Non-Canadians can think of Zellers like a colder,
more polite version of Kmart — a large,
national chain of discount department stores.
And like Kmart, it was, by the early 2010s,
more of a 90s time capsule than an actual store.
But — to its credit — rather than merely watch as
its brand slowly aged into inevitable bankruptcy,
like a certain company whose
name rhymes with “Spears”,
it threw in the towel and sold its
only asset that still had value: land.
The Zellers name may not have meant much,
but its nearly 200 leases certainly did.
Meanwhile, Target was rapidly
approaching saturation in America.
After nearly two decades of 8% average growth,
only 10 new stores were built in all of 2010.
And where better to expand to than its friendly,
northern neighbor — the one just 225 miles
from Target’s corporate headquarters?
Besides the obvious cultural and
linguistic overlap, about 300,000
people cross what is the longest
border in the world each day.
The company estimated that one in
every ten Canadians had shopped
at an American Target during the previous year.
Besides, many U.S. corporations
have done well up north.
Of Canada’s top 10 retailers
by revenue, five are American.
This was not, all of this is to say, a crazy idea.
With similar demographics,
pre-existing brand awareness,
and relatively few cultural differences,
Target Canada had everything going for it.
The only thing holding it back
was the size of its stores.
There just aren’t that many 1-200,000 square
foot buildings with Pentagon-sized parking lots.
Then along came Zellers. This was the
opportunity Target had been waiting for.
In 2011, Target paid $1.8 billion Canadian
dollars to buy 189 Zellers stores, 54 of
which it immediately re-sold to other companies,
including none other than its good friend Walmart.
There was, however, one major catch. From the
moment the deal was signed, the clock was ticking.
Not only was every day spent cleaning,
remodeling, and renovating these stores a
day it wasn’t making money, but Target bought
only the leases, not the land, outright.
They still had to deal with landlords.
Landlords who weren’t too keen on letting
these huge buildings sit empty — or worse —
bustling with construction for years on end.
To avoid deterring shoppers from other stores in
the area, it all had to happen fast. Really fast.
Bringing these retail museums into the
21st century required more than a fresh
coat of paint. About $10-11 million
worth of work for each location.
Still, Target trudged ahead on
what it called “Project Bacon”,
starting with the launch of three
Ontario stores in March of 2013.
Their signs, which read “We’re open (mostly)”
hinted at the disaster soon to come.
For the next 10 months, Target opened one
new Canadian store every 2 days on average.
It was the quickest expansion in company
history — a feat that continued through 2014.
But first, Target had a serious problem.
It wasn’t a lack of demand — Canadians
were eager to give the company a chance.
The problem was a lack of inventory.
Shelf after shelf sat totally empty.
One week, almost every item featured on
Target’s promotional flier was out of stock.
With nothing to buy, it’s no wonder
Target’s Canadian stores sold far
less merchandise than their American counterparts.
It all traced back to a single
decision made months earlier.
And to understand why, we’ll need to
take a brief detour into everyone’s
favorite dinner table topic — the
wonderful world of enterprise software.
And it’s only right that you hear
this in the form of a PowerPoint…
Huge, billion-dollar mega-corporations such as,
for example, e.g. Target are simply too
big for any one person to keep track of.
So, naturally, they turn to… computers! More
specifically, something called ERP — Enterprise
Resource Planning. You can think of ERP
like the mother of all excel spreadsheets.
For the kids, an all-knowing,
all-seeing Notion dashboard.
Your company’s ERP system knows how many
fractions of a cent it costs to ship this
lamp from distribution center to store, how
many different colors this couch comes in,
and at what exact point to re-order more dark-blue
oversized throw blankets based on the time
of year, recent sales, and diesel prices.
Simply put: ERP is the brain
of a giant corporation.
Target already had its own, custom
ERP built for America — but it was
designed to work only in English,
with U.S. Dollars, inches, and feet.
So, rather than try to
jury-rig its American system,
Target opted to start fresh,
to buy a new ERP called SAP.
Spoiler alert: this was a terrible idea.
Now, back to your regular scheduled programming…
To Target executives, this sounded
like the best, most sensible,
long-term decision. Better to rip the band-aid off
quickly by switching to the software used by all
the Fortune 500 companies, the one trusted
by Disney, and Burger King, and Coca-Cola.
To anyone in the tech industry, however,
this was an obvious recipe for disaster.
The first thing to understand
about SAP is how it makes money.
Like many enterprise software companies,
it’s just as much in the consulting business
as it is in the writing software business.
In fact, providing support can be so profitable
that it’s not unheard of for companies
to give away their software for free.
This, for instance, is SAP’s third
quarter 2022 investor report.
You can see that at least 38% of its
revenue came from “software support”.
Anyone who's ever had the misfortune of
using enterprise software knows the secret:
when the people — executives — who buy the
software don’t themselves use it, it sucks.
But because SAP also makes a huge chunk of
its money from support, it’s even worse.
How much incentive do they really
have to make it easy-to-use?
Now, the point is not that SAP doesn’t have its
uses. There’s a reason so many companies buy it.
When ERP systems work, they can do
things no human could possibly do.
And if SAP weren’t dependable,
Disney wouldn’t be using them.
But for them to be dependable, the data you feed
them has to be perfect. Garbage in, garbage out.
And by “data”, we’re talking about the width,
height, length, color, weight, quantity,
description, price, and so on for every last
one of the 75,000 unique items sold by Target.
Now add French, an entirely
different system of measurement,
and a new currency to the mix — not to mention
the difficulty of learning to use SAP — and you
can see how this was fundamentally incompatible
with Target Canada’s extremely tight deadline.
Software, famously, is finished when it’s
finished. Even on the best of days, deadlines,
schedules, and road-maps
are just wishful thinking.
Implementing an ERP is no different.
However long you think it might take,
add a couple years, and, congratulations,
you’ve discovered the best case scenario.
Sobeys, Canada’s second-largest
supermarket, gave up on SAP despite
spending 4 years and $89 million after
its databases were shut down for 5 days.
Another company’s transition took
two years longer than expected.
So, you can probably guess what
happened when Target Canada tried
to do the whole thing in two years…
complete, unmitigated disaster.
While its store shelves sat empty,
products piled up in distribution
centers. Target had all the inventory
it needed — it just didn’t know where.
Eventually, the company was forced
to rent extra storage space.
It soon discovered the culprit — a mere 30% of the
information entered into the system was accurate.
The other 70% might be measured in
inches, misspelled, or simply missing.
Faced with no other option, the
entire Target merchandising team
spent days manually verifying the
information for all 75,000 products.
On top of this, analysts, whose
performance was measured based
on their ability to keep products in
stock, had completely turned off the
automatic replenishment system
so they wouldn’t be penalized.
Target wasn’t just flying blind — its
gauges were feeding it false information.
How could it possibly take-off
successfully under those conditions?
Now, as bad as this was — and, it was bad,
it probably wasn’t fatal. Supply chains are
just plain hard and it always takes time for
companies to acclimate to a new environment.
Nor was it any big scandal that Target’s
prices were about 15% higher in Canada.
The country is about 9 times less
densely populated than the United States,
which makes it much more expensive
to get products into stores.
Every last item for all 133
stores was sourced from one
of just three distribution centers
— in Milton, Balzac, and Cornwall.
The latter, therefore, had to ship
products as far away as St. John’s,
Newfoundland — a 1,600-mile,
33-hour drive and ferry ride away.
Not to mention: fuel is more expensive in Canada.
But for prices to be visibly
higher and for shelves to be
routinely empty was simply a stretch too far.
By 2014, just 18% of surveyed Canadians said
they were “very satisfied” with the company.
Above all, though, the true
fatal flaw in Target’s plan,
the real root of its problems,
was the deal with Zellers.
Had it tested the market with one or two stores
to begin with, like J Crew and Nordstrom did,
it would’ve had the necessary focus to
correct any speed bumps and learn from them.
Instead, sparks soon turned into a 133-store
forest fire. It was too much, too fast.
It also didn’t help that many of these
stores were in sub-par locations.
When it entered Canada, Target wasn’t “Tar-jey”,
it was a fresh coat of paint over a former Kmart.
All the shiny bright red spheres in
the world couldn’t make up for the fact
these buildings were situated in run-down
strip malls and C-Class shopping centers.
The company lost $940 million in the first year
alone, and the problem only compounded from there.
So, after a widely-publicized data breach,
followed by a couple of lackluster holiday
seasons — the bread-and-butter of retail
— Target Canada looked for an exit.
And on April 1st, 2015 — just
757 days after the first store
opened — Target announced it was leaving Canada.
Despite spending $7 billion, hiring
17,000 employees, and taking over 133
stores, it left with hardly a trace.
This was the Zellers’ liquidation sale in
2011 and this was the Target liquidation sale,
possibly at the very same location,
just a few short years later.
One store in Ottawa was completely
finished but unopened at the time.
The pristine, untouched Target was sold
to Walmart, along with dozens of others.
And Canadians, 75% of whom live
less than 100 miles from America,
quietly went back to crossing the border.
It was as if one of the biggest disasters
in retail history never happened.
One thing that, I hope, will leave
an impression is my video debunking
the myth that China “lifted 800
million people out of poverty”.
This persistent myth has been
used as a sort of “get out of
jail free card” by the authorities
in Beijing. There’s a dark history
behind this claim — one that would
surely get demonetized on YouTube.
And that’s precisely why we created
Nebula, the streaming platform built
by and for independent creators. There are
no ads, videos like mine are available days
earlier, and you get exclusive access to
content that will never air on YouTube.
Content like my 6-part series “China,
Actually”, Neo’s “Under Exposure”,
or RealLifeLore’s “Modern Conflicts”.
Personally, I check the front
page of Nebula several times
a day and I’m amazed by how often new,
exclusive Original content is released.
All these came out in just the
last few weeks, for instance.
Now, normally, Nebula costs $5 a month.
But you can get it for just half that by
signing up for a year with the link
on screen or in the description now.
That’s just $2.50 a month for loads
of exclusive content you’ll love.